*War Music*
'Pokimane, Alinity, and Ray William Johnson.
What do all these people have in common? They are copystriking! That's right,
all these people have history of copy striking videos.
Now, there's nothing inherently wrong about copystriking okay?
But I think the motivation behind these copyright strikes, is um...
*stops war music*
...Worth mentioning at least.
Recently, Jameskii made a video talking about how his channel face getting- almost shut down
um,
because he got a copyright strike over someone not liking what he said on a video.
Now,
I personally have a lot of experience with copyright and I think it's for the best interest of everyone on this site that
um...
...We talked about this in today's video, and also so I can get more watchtime.
So...
...do keep watching guys.
*Equals Three sound effect*
Our first Twitch thot is Ray William Johnson.
Remember Ray?
Ray William Johnson copyright strike a channel called “Hoover”.
[HOOVER] Ray William Johnson
himself, --(I'm pretty sure)-- took down the [bass] video.
Now I have no idea why he did, but I checked the claim
he claimed the entire video, the 12 minutes, the entire thing.
So the outro was his,
the original bits I put in was his,
the parts where we just talked was his.
Now, normally out of final appeal obviously
But the thing is if he's taking on the whole video and then he this looks at the appeal and he fucking takes it down
That's the copyright strike on my ass. There's no real good parts of this
So the title of the video that was taken down by ray, william johnson was interestingly
Ray william. Johnson thinks he can sing and it was basically a video mocking
raveling johnson's old singing
Career or his old music essentially and he begs the question would this video have been taken down if it was called?
Raveling johnson sings like an angel ray. William. Johnson underrated musical genius. I don't think so
Ok, now the video is back up again
So I assume they resolved this but I think it's important to note that this didn't just get
Resolved because ray william johnson thought to himself. Maybe I shouldn't have taken down that video. I'll remove the claim. No it got
most likely thanks to a lot of youtubers raising their voice and helping this channel and a lot of public outrage on Twitter the
Copyright claim got removed. I find this extremely hypocritical
Coming from someone that even went to court to fight for fair use raywilliamjohnson who made a career?
Essentially from other people's content reacting to it adding their own commentary to it. Just like Hoover did now to be fair
I appreciate that. Raywilliamjohnson took down the claim. I also can't say for sure what the motivation behind the claim was originally
I can't say for a fact that it was because people were ridiculing him
I think what we'll find today here is a common theme people just didn't like what was in the video
Therefore it was taken down. I already know example of illinit II, but I'll bring it up because I think is important nonetheless
This is so annoying
stupid
Twitch thought uni, they win over me. Okay, and they're not gonna win over me stupid twitch thoughts. No
Seriously he use that that
I'm gonna copy strike this guy
Just for that word
gonna copy strike him
Yo, so I didn't even call Alena D a twitch thought I just used a word basically that was enough for her to think
Oh, I'm gonna claim the revenue out of that video and it I think this revealed the second problem with copyright strikes
They sending me 700 dollars last month
from copy strike hitting people
Good money. So this reveal the second problem with copyright strike
Which is the motivation for monetary games of striking other people's content
basically
If you claim a video you get all that revenue from that video
So illinit e here try to use the motivation of he used two bad word against me
So therefore I all that revenue in that video, that's mine now. Thank you very much. My revenue. Oh, I was in that person's video
Yes, I mean it's basically theft and there's so many companies that partner up with streamers
Specifically just so they can claim reuploaded content on YouTube which in a way I can understand but I also find it extremely ironic
Because usually streamers commentary is just them sitting there. They're not adding any thing to it
I don't even know why people bother reuploading these at least youtubers can argue that their work is transformative
Understand each other the world will be a better place. That's right. That's all I care about
I just want people to be happy trust me. That's my number one priority
Smash like on this video. Sorry, we'll get that abuse. That would help me out a lot. Thank you very much for watching
Make sure to hit sponsor it
so become a sponsor so you can see that and
That's it for me for now. Thank you guys so much for watching. I'll see you guys -
Okay, hey Shrout hit subscribe
Goddammit, what are you doing? I'm not here to call shout out. Okay on anything else but him subscribing third example
Exhibit C
Veronica Wang
Disappointing. I thought I gave her the benefit of the doubt
But basically she striked a channel to the point that it almost got deleted
Why why because she didn't like what that channels content was about her
she didn't like how the video was making fun of her and she didn't like how people
Watching the video making fun of her was making even more fun of her essentially
I'm a representation to my subscribers and I want to show them that it's okay to stand up for yourself
So I made a video of me making fun of myself
Literally a video of me making fun of myself to show people, you know, if anyone's gonna be allowed to make fun of me
It's gonna be me
So this reveals another big problem in my opinion
Which is fairly similar to the pokey - situation Exhibit D
Pokey main she strike this video called keemstar versus Pokemon Twitter fight bullying Sniper Wolf fanboy
Now I know about this video because it was pushed everywhere by YouTube
It was basically a Twitter feud between keemstar and pokey mind. They uploaded videos to each other
I don't know cuz King sir is illiterate. And for some reason Pokemon decided. Yeah, I'll make a video as well
None that nevertheless someone decided to put these two videos in together and upload it on YouTube
Then the YouTube algorithm thought oh, this is an interesting video that people want to watch and pushed it everywhere
So basically this Twitter drama became even bigger drama. Thanks. YouTube's algorithm
so in a way, I can understand why you want to take down this video because this
Selected thing blows up and becomes even bigger. Thanks to YouTube system being
kind of stupid at least I can somewhat understand the motivation of trying to take down that video but the problem here and
The same problem that goes with every single example that I brought up in this video is that you're just drawing more attention to it
It's the Streisand effect every single time the more you try and hide something the more people are gonna find out about it
That's what brought all these examples to lie. And I think what bothers me
most of all out of all of these is the hypocrisy
You know ray william johnson went to court for fair use
But strikes another channels content for uploading his okay
All these people that I brought up today have examples of using other people's content for their own content
They could all get copyright striked just the same way. They copyright strike other people or claim their videos
I don't know exactly what the percentage is
But I would say 90% of content on the internet or at least on YouTube in twitch
Isn't hundred percent original content. It's
Its commentary its reactions its reviews its gameplay. I mean people tell me all the time. Oh just make original content
Well, guess what? Every single gaming channel is not original content. They're reacting to someone else's video game. It's someone else's content
They don't own the rights to it
Just the same way with any other reaction, but it's fair use because it's transformative work because you're adding your commentary to it
remember when Sean vanaman decided to give me a DMCA takedown a copyright strike because
He didn't like what I said in a live stream that had nothing to do with his game
Despite the fact that they give public permission on their website. You're free to use our game
So basically they can revoke that at any given time
If anyone if you have permission to use someone's content
They can still give you a copyright strike because basically YouTube doesn't pay attention to any of that
I feel pretty confident that if I took Sean venneman to court or his company to fight this claim
Which is basically what a DM Said's that would in entitles if I fight against it
But I feel confident that I would win that and wasting him and his company time and money
Well my time as well, obviously it's not cheap either
I mean h3h3 went to court any constant one hundreds of thousands of dollars fifty thousand dollars
I think they hailed up a check for but the problem here is a YouTube's way
So insanely heavily towards the one making the claim the way the system works and I'll explain this for the hundredth time
I'm sorry for all this doing it
You can either get a claim or a copyright strike if the video gets claimed the video saves up
But they take all the revenue if you get a copyright strike the video goes down
but they still take all the revenue if a video gets claimed you as a creator have the choice to
Dispute that claim in saying no you're wrong for doing this claim and it's basically solely up to the one making the claim to say
Actually, no. I'm right so you're not just getting money, but you also dictate whether you're right or wrong
The system is so messed up
And if you say no twice to the clay to the claim, it automatically goes to a copyright strike
So basically as a creator if you get a claim, you're you're pretty screwed, but if you're the one making the claim
There's basically no repre conscience. I mean you could claim whatever you want. YouTube isn't gonna go
Hey stop doing that and as a creator, you just risk your channel getting shut down
I mean that's what happened to James key now because of him getting a copyright strike if you get a copyright claim and you say
Okay, we'll take this to court then. That's the only way we can settle this the history of this happening which is two examples
h3 h3 and raywilliamjohnson
And they both argue that their content was transformative and fair and it applies under fair use and guess what they want
making commentary on own videos and adding your
Reactions and all that - it does apply under fair use at least from what we've seen so far
so if you copyright strike a channel or even claim a channel you
Run the risk of actually going to court and losing a lot of money
So it's generally a terrible idea to abuse this system
which so many people seem to do without even thinking about the wreck questions because YouTube doesn't really
apply it instantly it is a
Terrible idea to do this. Not just for monetary
Purposes but also because everyone will hate you. I mean the only thing really holding the YouTube system together at this point
It's the public outcry or the public outrage towards people that abuse the system and if that wasn't the case
I mean the whole thing would just go rampant. You also just draw more attention to what you're trying to hide
So just stop can you just stop abuse and copyright? It's not that hard
Just don't take down videos, even if it shows you in a negative way. It's a terrible idea
Stop doing it
Stop taking down videos YouTube needs to add a takedown request
The only way to take down a video right now is through a copyright strike a takedown request. Let's just say
okay, you give the user two to three days to take down the video and then if they say no at that period then it
Goes to a copyright strike
The way it works right now is the only way to take down a video is through a copyright strike
I think having a takedown request would solve a lot of problems
I mean, there's been times where me myself had to do a copyright strike because there was a video
I just wanted to be shown for a specific time and I asked people please don't really this video because they only wait for me
To take it down is to give it a copyright strike and people did it
Anyway, people still real go to the video and I was like, alright
Well, I have to give you a copyright strike now like I didn't want to do this
But YouTube has no other way to take down a video
So a takedown request at least would be some fair warning in between at least now my final point. I'm sorry
It's been super long
My final point is a few years back Nintendo announced that
basically to upload Nintendo games on YouTube
You need to be part of their partnership
Program me personally and a lot of other people criticized this idea because it's just a bad idea
You're just gonna miss out on a lot of free marketing
which is basically what this is people playing games and lo and behold now they announced they're shutting the program down the way the
Ecosystem YouTube works or on the Internet in general is that most people benefit from sharing these different things?
Game developers know that it's free marketing for people to play their games. They even pay youtubers to play their game
They even pay to make it seem like it. There are youtubers playing their game even though they're just actors
That's how effective this whole sharing thing works the ecosystem works people
Watching and reacting to other people's videos that helps that creator
They receive some of sharing content is something that everyone benefits from not just for promotion
But also it makes everything so much more fun in my opinion. It's what makes memes fun and all these different references and whatever
It's already so bad with people abusing copyright strikes. Just stop
copyright striking videos
Okay
Just stop making it worse for literally everyone YouTube's tool have the tools for everyone to make a copyright strike
Stop abusing it. It's bad enough already now with article 13
You've probably already heard about it's just gonna make it even worse
There's 11 days left before an article 13 will be decided upon
I highly encourage you to sign this petition
Right now sign the petition we need to protect the internet YouTube system works
It works too. Good. That's the problem
Stuff we'll be using the system and sign this goddamn tradition. That's it. Thank you guys so much. Love you guys so much
See you guys tomorrow. Bye
Bye you thought the video was over?
80 million club merch is here. Everybody. Can we copies right this guy?
80 million club, that's right everybody. Thank you for 80 million subscribers. Cuz yeah
Very epic Merc check it out link in the description limited time only sayonara bro sugamice what the actual?